this great big story was made possible
by IBM culturally and traditionally
speaking when girls were born we're not
to go too into spam which is science
technology engineering and maths they
were thought to go into other kind of
fields and sectors but now we are
changing that because we believe we all
belong there welcome to this is a
vestroia
she created an initiative called you
guessed it girls coding it's aimed at
teaching girls from disadvantaged
backgrounds in Nigeria how to program as
the name defeats girls learning computer
programming girls are developing skills
as software programmers it's it stems
from my own personal journey I've been
in their shoes I personally had a bit of
rough background growing up and
technology and the world of computer
programming really helped me I believe
young girls regardless of their
background can also have a voice through
technology it started back in 2015
since then they've been able to teach
coding to over 420 girls the kind of
skills we teach and girls food in
programming tools such as HTML hypertext
markup language CSS which is cascading
style sheets Python Java Java scripts
must realize and of course mentoring is
also a key part of what we do girls come
from all sorts of backgrounds many come
from the slums around Legos the majority
grow up thinking that education isn't an
option for them you can choose to
actually bring other people to this life
in a different and better circumstances
and situation I can choose to make
something great out of yourself so your
background does not have to define your
future but a few times a week when they
join this class they get a glimpse of a
whole other world seen a lot of girls
who have never seen computers before now
can teach adults what do you know it
amazing they've gone from writing
problems and solutions on paper to see a
mobile have developed out of it
and these are teens they've been able to
do themselves when I grew up our lights
become a medical doctor on TV a computer
science programmer I want to become a
lawyer I hope to become a mathematician
and a programmer I believe Africa can
offer the world all lots especially if
you can invest in our talents in the
potential of young people and make them
build things that pertains to Africans
so when you invest in people or you make
them thinkers become build world-class
solutions to problems and that is
massive
[Music]